hey Donald Trump called our voicemail
number the number is two one nine to
david p he had sort of just a final
message before the election hello David
it's me Donald I've been watching your
program recently and I just have to say
I really don't appreciate what you've
been saying about me you and your little
co store a bunch of [ __ ] and if I
weren't so busy right now I'd grab you
guys maybe even buy the [ __ ] to throw
you out of the broadcasting community
entirely you don't know anything about
business I'm a successful businessman
you make terrible deals you're every bit
as crooked as Hillary is and I want to
let you know everything you say about me
is wrong if I do get elected I'm going
to make this country great we're going
to win we're going to win what we never
won before I'm going to make really
great deals you don't know how to make
deals David you have no clue what you're
talking about but I've gotta go so don't
say anything bad about me again
including the size of my hands my hands
are very nicely said hands David so okay
good luck David
in goodbye how would you rate on a scale
of one to ten this Trump impersonator
impressions quite good and he the best
part about it is he hit on every single
trum ISM there you musta scripted it out
did he say tremendous you know I
probably did yeah I'm not sure if he's a
tremendous I give this about a seven I
think this is a seven in terms of a
voice Trump impersonation uh very very
funny no idea who that is I don't think
it's a caller that is called in before
so we couldn't tie it back like oh it's
the egg man or Troy York or Louisiana
troll or Kansas troll who by the way uh
I don't know what's happened to the
Kansas troll he hasn't called in for a
very very long time on the bonus show
today I will tell my early voting story
Pat will tell his early voting story we
will talk about what is going on with
voting so far we will preview live
coverage that we will be doing tonight
once again live coverage of the election
tonight
the goal is 6:45 p.m. Eastern time just
before the 7 o'clock results come in we
will be starting our live coverage we
will give you results at 7:00 p.m.
the plan is to go to Sam cedar over in
Brooklyn New York at the majority report
studios just blocks from my
Department in Brooklyn New York check in
with him about 7:15 Bendixon will be
here gonna be a whole thing so please
tune in on YouTube live youtube.com
slash the david pakman show starting at
unless something goes wrong 6:45 p.m.
Eastern tonight don't miss today's bonus
show and remember get your 2017 David
Pakman show calendar this is a beautiful
calendar I don't know that I've ever
seen a more beautiful calendar uh it's
just tremendous it's it's an insanely
good calendar with art designed by david
pakman show viewer and artist Dan Burke
you will see all of your favorite David
Pakman show and political characters
here including former producer Louis get
the calendar for free at david
pakman.com slash calendar 17 the goal is
350 calendars we are about I think 52 or
53 is the last count please get your
calendars you can get just the calendar
you can get it signed or not signed you
can get the calendar with a membership
if you want david pakman.com slash
calendar 17 free shipping in the united
states no matter where you are very
exciting we will talk about that and
voting and the election and so much more
on the bonus show which all of our
members have instant access to once they
sign up speak to you then go vote